so yesterday I told you that Senate
Majority Leader Mitch McConnell has an
opponent who actually could be quite
strong her name's Amy McGrath and Mitch
McConnell as I've told you over the
years as Senate Majority Leader has been
a very effective Republican operative
for all of the reasons that I've
previously laid out and I told you
yesterday and it would be close to as
important close to his big of an
accomplishment I would say to remove
Mitch McConnell in 2020 as it would be
to remove Donald Trump in 2020 but as I
told you yesterday without rehashing the
entire story Kentucky is very red there
are real obstacles for Amy McGrath who's
a former Marine fighter pilot but
there's at least some good news early
that gives us some sense of hope and at
least the idea that this is a race that
is worth investing time and money into
Amy McGrath has raised more than two and
a half million dollars in the first 24
hours running against Mitch and if you
thought that Lindsey Graham's opponent
Jamie Harrison was doing well by raising
a million and a half dollars in general
against Lindsey Graham Amy McGrath has
raised two and a half million in 24
hours and the McGrath campaign is
claiming and at least for now I haven't
been able to find conflicting
information the McGrath campaign claims
that two and a half million bucks in the
first 24 hours is a record for the first
24 hours of any Senate campaign period
which sort of sounds like a big claim
but I researched it this morning and I
was not able to find anything to
contradict it average donation to Amy
McGrath is about $36 the 2.5 million
does not include money that was sent in
via check checks written during the
first 24 hours but which will of course
not be received for another couple of
days and money also pledged but not yet
given which I don't know exactly maybe
at fundraisers money can be pledged but
they don't immediately necessarily
collect it I don't know where this
started but I like the sound of when you
do the math you choose McGrath I think
that that's a nice little slogan for her
also an anti Mitch McConnell slogan
would be something like let's put a
hurdle in front of the turtle which is
absolutely fantastic and maybe Amy
McGrath will be the person to do
it's the candidate who served her
country against the guy who only ever
serves himself I saw that one on reddit
somewhere now once again managing
expectations I told you yesterday this
will be tough
Kentucky is very red just because lots
of Kentucky Republicans don't like Mitch
McConnell and many of them don't that
doesn't mean that they're going to go
out and vote for a Democrat in November
of 2020 many would prefer a different
Republican but in the end will either
vote for Mitch McConnell over a Democrat
or simply not vote at all but there is a
chance here in 2008 McConnell won by
just six points in 2014 McConnell won by
16 points so in a presidential election
year it was way closer than in a midterm
all we can do is run each race Graham
and McConnell are two races I'm going to
be watching I was tweeting yesterday
with JD Shelton you might remember JD
Schulten ran against totally disgusting
xenophobic white nationalist I don't
know I don't know that I'd call my white
nationalist but sensitive to white
nationalism or cuddler of white
nationalism Steve King in Iowa in 2018
and I met JD Scholten at Netroots nation
last year actually was yes last year and
I asked him whether he's planning to run
again in 2020 against Steve King and he
says he hasn't made a decision yet that
would be a really great race as well so
things are getting going I'll be telling
you about interesting races as I see
them let me know if there are specific
2020 races that you want me to cover I
will tell you it's difficult for us to
do a lot of pre primary interviews
because in a lot of these races where
there's for example an incumbent
Republican there will be six Democrats
running in the primary and they all want
to be interviewed on the show and we
can't really turn the David Pakman show
as I've said before like into the
California seventh district show so
interviews are tough at least
pre-primary but we do want a spotlight
important races where either Republicans
could be knocked off or corporate
Democrats are potentially going to go
down so let me know what races
to be following